Geeked Week.
Hey what's up, everybody?
I'm Mari Takahashi.
And I'm Geoff Keighley.
Welcome to Netflix Geeked Week.
The sequel, right?
Yes! The sequel.
Our second year doing this.
GEEKED Week 2022, baby.
It's great to be back here
with you, Goeff.
I know. It was just a year ago.
I feel like we were at summer game fest
with our good buddy Rahul.
Yeah that's right!
Talking about Netflix gaming shows.
This year
though, we've also got Netflix games,
and I'm thrilled to have Netflix
as part of the summer game fest this year.
So shout out to everyone watching
on the game awards channel right now.
And also to everyone
co-streaming on Twitch.
That's right. It's not just about me.
It's about everyone in the community.
Everyone here for the big breaking news.
That's right.
All week
long, Netflix has been dropping trailers
and big news about series and movies.
But today it is
all about the thing that we love.
It's all about games, baby.
That's right, Mari.
You know, last year when we were here,
it was just shows based on games.
But today we'll also be announcing
some games based on shows.
You guys with us?
Plus some well-loved
mobile games are coming to Netflix
and some brand new games from developers
like Devolver Digital.
It's so awesome to see Netflix
in the gaming business.
So shows, games, everything you want about
Netflix and games right here today.
Which is a lot to unpack.
This is the very first time
we get to cover Netflix games
and this incredible lineup.
There's so much. There's so much stuff.
So are we going to start with a game
or a show?
That's a good question.
We're announcing a brand new series
based on a massively popular
video game, which doesn't give you a lot,
but I'm sure you'll tell us what I know.
It could just be about anything,
but it is a world exclusive trailer.
You know, I love those. Check this out.
A New Saga Begins.
We're in.
Dragon Age: Absolution
Dragon Age Absolution Dragon Age.
This is exciting because everyone's
awaiting the next Dragon Age.
I think we announced it
in the game, awards
like three or four years ago
and while we wait for the game now,
we get an incredible new show
and it looks amazing.
I'm curious about how it fits together,
but it's called Dragon Age.
Absolution.
Oh yeah!
I played Inquisition, and I remember
I mean, there's so much lore
when it comes to Dragon Age, right?
And so I'm really excited
where, like you said,
we're we're going to be plopped in
and how all of that lore
is going to be kind of spoonfed to me
because I feel like it's
just the best pieces of it
and we're going to get all of those.
And it's been, I think, quite a while
since we've had new Dragon Age lore.
I mean, it's
been a long time since we've had a game.
No one is in development, so it's great
that we're getting this ahead of,
I think the game even.
I mean with dragon ages, elves and mages
and Qunari.
And it's really cool to expand
on the Dragon Age series.
Absolutely. And it looks great.
That was a nice surprise.
I didn't even know that was coming.
So great news and that's not all.
Here's
a closer look at the brand new poster
for the show that we are
premiering here on GEEKED Week.
Check it out.
Who is she?
I know.
Yeah, that's what's cool is I love
now that the game companies and Netflix,
everyone are thinking about the stuff
holistically and kind of introducing
like lore and characters
sometimes in an anime or a comic book
before the game.
Hopefully it somehow ties in,
but I have no idea
who that hopefully is a new character
that maybe we'll get to meet in the game.
Maybe the first in the series. Yeah.
I want to know what class she is.
She looks like she
she might be an elf, but who knows?
Yeah. What's her name?
What's her backstory?
These are all the things we're probably
not even getting answers to today,
but I am very excited to learn more.
And I got to say,
the series looks incredible.
Yeah. I love the animation style too.
Everyone don't miss the rich lore in world
building of Dragon Age Absolution.
All right.
We are going to keep our eyes on that.
That was a nice surprise.
A big way to kick off GEEKED Week gaming.
And if you want to rewatch
that gorgeous trailer,
we just put it up on Twitter at Netflix
Geeked.
This next series is sure to be a...are
you ready?
Yep. Hit. Oh,
yes. We're talking about Tekken:Bloodline.
I love it.
I got to say, when I was a kid
growing up in Canada,
I loved playing Tekken in the Arcades
and that on PlayStation.
This is such a classic fighting franchise.
It's been a few years
since we've had a new Tekken, but now this
iconic fighting game
franchise is now an anime
coming to Netflix and it's sure to please
old and new fans alike.
Yeah, I mean, again,
the animation style is so interesting.
Today
we have a special treat for Tekken fans,
a message from Creator,
Katsuhiro Harada-so excited to see it.
Let's roll it.
That was so cool-Harada-I mean that's Mr.
Tekken!
That's why I love about all this stuff
that Netflix does is
Harada is directly involved as you can see
in building this out and partnering
with Netflix to make a Tekken story
which I wouldn't have guessed a Tekken
animator would be on the on the menu
but it looks incredible.
I mean like you said it's for the fans
from the source itself
which makes it so so much better.
Cool fighting of course.
I think
that's all going to be implemented,
but it sounds like there's going to be
so much more depth to the story.
We're going to really get to see Jin
and his mother Jun sort of relationship
and what all of that means
for the entire series itself.
Very exciting.
I was going to say, and I'm sure there's
going to be some incredible action
as we would expect,
and it is so cool to see Harada-San.
Good to see you, my friend.
Hope he's
also working on another Tekken game,
but he is an icon in the fighting game
community and a badass in his own right.
A legendary personality and of course,
legendary sunglasses, legendary outfits.
Harada always shows up with style.
Yeah. Where
can we get the Harada glasses, huh?
I say we should end the show in our Harada
glasses.
We should!
Be sure to head over to Twitter
for more Tekken news
at NetflixGEEKED to stay on top of it.
And for all things anime,
you know what to do.
Smash that follow button
on Twitter for NetflixAnime.
So if you didn't know over
the last year, Netflix has started
including a bunch of great mobile games
as part of your membership.
That's right.
This is a brand new thing
Netflix introduced late last year,
and there are no ads,
no micro-transactions,
and a huge variety of games
that are constantly being updated.
For everyone who is a Netflix subscriber,
no additional cost.
Here's a taste of the games
you can find right now.
I want that as my theme song.
It's so good,
it's so
diverse,
and I feel like my Netflix homepage
in general looks that diverse,
too-with the stuff that I watch
and to see that reflected in the games,
that's really cool.
To start off
we have a few based off of some
of the most popular Netflix series.
Our first one is coming to you
straight from the fold.
There are no others like us
and there never will be.
We have no idea how much larger a role
you have to play.
There we go.
That's right.
Shadow and Bone is getting a game, y'all.
Shadow and Bone
Destinies is a narrative RPG with Rogue
like elements based on the beloved show,
based on Lee Bardugo's books.
In this game you play as your favorite
characters and journey across the world
of the Grishaverse in a narrative
adventure to fulfill your destinies.
Along the way,
you'll need to make decisions
that will determine the course
of your journey.
It's being created
by Chimera entertainment.
And we actually learned on Monday
that the production
has officially wrapped on season
two of the show.
So Shadow and Bone fans,
we are eating good this year.
Whether you're a Darklina stan
or at Melina supremacy,
whatever that means, be sure to follow
Netflix Geeked on Instagram.
OK, so Geoff, you were saying
that there's a wide variety of games
on Netflix, which is true.
And I got a look at your second game
today.
And yeah, I think this is exactly for you.
They finally made a game for your personal
favorite Netflix show, Geoff.
Nailed it.
I'm very excited.
Too Hot To Handle! Oh my god,
coming from developer Nano Bit based off
the hit-That's right-Hit
Netflix reality show it is you're right
Mari-Too Hot to Handle-the game.
See finally Jeff,
they've been listening to you.
Twitch chat
I'm sure it's just I can't even imagine
what's going on down the chat you guys.
But here you go
too hot to handle this is actual
a real game it is coming to Netflix.
That's right in
just like too hot to handle the series
expect the game to feature
lots of innuendos
and fun plot twists
and of course, romance.
I'm just mesmerized watching the dialogue
go out there.
Select, select your outfit. Oh, my God.
Oh, ha.
The game follows the TV show rules,
and the players goal
is to find the best partner
by going through episodes
and making their own decisions,
basically their own season.
How fun is that? Just talking about
she sells real estate.
I'm reading all the
dialogue here as we go on.
She blushes how about you, gorgeous?
I didn't catch your name.
Maybe we should just
read the B-roll till the end of the show.
Anyways.
I'm definitely not
getting the prize money.
I don't think but I'll try it again.
Out of all the games
that will be announced
today,
I will tell you, walking in this door
this morning, I did not expect to see
a Too Hot to Handle game.
All right.
Well, the show is absolutely insane
if you haven't seen it.
So if you want to dive in
while you wait for the game,
Too Hot to Handle is on Netflix,
the first three seasons, right now.
OK, Geoff, I don't know about you.
Can we recover from that, Mari?
Yeah, no, I don't think there's ever
recovering from that.
Season four. Season. Four.
Get this guy on the show.
Say, all right, well, so
now we got to...where do we go from there?
We're pivoting.
We are pivoting straight
to some badass action OK,
I don't know about you,
but my Netflix list is this conglomeration
of the Too hot to handles,
you know, the reality TV shows
and then also like epic, awesome, badass
stories.
So, yeah, of course,
we're going to be talking about that next.
OK, well, we've got some epic stories
and even more epic games like our next one
like Casa de Papel
this show is a global phenomenon,
and now Netflix has partnered
with the developer
Kill us off to put you behind the mask.
Oh, intriguing.
This is an adventure game
featuring an original standalone story
set in the la Casa de Papel universe.
It's kind of a cool cel shade.
I wasn't expecting that. Yeah.
Are you ready to sneak by cameras, crawl
through vents, hack security systems,
and silently knock out your enemies
to pull off the world's biggest heist.
Metal Gear Papel, right?
Yeah, that's right.
This is a huge
international phenomenon, this show.
And it's so cool.
Again, this is like
this is a real adaptation,
and I think it's a very stylized
take on this game right now.
I was, like, joking, like Metal Gear.
It's like it's obviously it's
a very action oriented heist sort of game.
And this is, you know, feels very
strategic, too, and how you go through it.
So it looks like they've got safe
cracking and everything.
That's right.
Safe cracking,
lock picking, mini games, shooting
sequences, and,
of course, the heist going awry.
Anything can happen.
That's why I don't know how they do it
so quietly.
I just feel like I would make
some kind of noise in the vent.
Oh, yeah,
every game has some sort of vent, right?
You got to have the vent system .
There's all of this and much, much more
in the game based on La Casa de Papel.
Now, speaking of classic Netflix shows,
over the past few years,
we all remember when the Queen's Gambit
inspired a chess revolution.
That's right.
Everyone was watching that show,
and then everyone was playing
chess.
Chess isn't always competitive.
Chess can also be
beautiful.
Now you can enter Beth Harmon's world
because there's a new game
coming out from developer RipStone.
Inspired by the Queen's Gambit series.
That's right.
And it's not just a chess board.
We have the first ever
look at the trailer for the game.
Let's check it out.
This game serves as a love
letter to the series.
You can really see it
with the aesthetics already.
You can play competitors online
like we just mentioned,
or you can play against characters
from the series in beautiful settings.
That's probably how we would play, right?
Not online, but just...
Beautiful, relaxing game of chess.
You can learn chess with Mr.
Scheibel or compete with Borgov
or challenge Beth to matches.
Speaking of lovely locations-in
the park.
Lovely.
Let's take a look at all these locations
you can play in
Beth's house as her career grows.
You can go to the house.
You can go to the orphanage
where Beth learned how to play chess.
And how about Las Vegas?
Because that's
where she ultimately faced her test.
Vegas chess game at the bar, sure. Yeah.
And plus, there's tons of puzzles and
challenges to keep your skills nice Check.
Checkmate.
Check it out if you want more info on
how to play The Queen's Gambit,
check out NetflixGeeked on Instagram.
Oh, I'm excited for this next one.
Oh, my God.
Last year we had so much fun
talking about this, and now it's back.
That's right.
Next up, we have a show based on a game
based on some old timey cartoons.
If that gives you a little bit of a hint.
And it's a knockout.
If you're looking for fun.
We got the heebie jeebies.
-- welcome to the Cuphead
-- Welcome to the Cuphead Show.
I'll get that Cup.
Oh, shut up.
The Cuphead show.
Oh, my God.
This is this is awesome.
One of my favorite shows. Yes. On Netflix.
I love the game.
The new DLC.
Delicious last course section
coming out later this month.
We just showed some stuff off
the summer game fest for that.
But this show is so fun because
the characters actually have voices.
Cuphead is always getting Mugman into
trouble, and it's just it's so delightful.
And I love that they're little snack of
episodes are like 10 minutes long.
I have so much fun watching.
There's nostalgia
in the way that it is animated,
of course, but it's also fresh.
Gosh, it is so good
and the music is so good.
Oh, yeah.
It brings so much more to the Cuphead lore
when you play delicious
last course thing,
it's going to mean that much more to you
now because we've watched these episodes.
The thing also is
that Cuphead is a very difficult game.
So I kind of like that
you can just watch this show
and not have to worry about dying
every 15 seconds.
It's true. True.
But the same amount of screaming
as me playing the game.
The screams of joy.
These screams of joy and laughter.
Yeah.
Now, if you guys love the Cuphead show
like me!
And like Mari.
Well, get ready to double down.
Check this out.
Gosh, Dallas, I'm
sorry I got you tossed in the hoosegow.
That's Slammer,
the Crowbar Hotel, the stony lonesome,
the convict condo, the old hoobah dobah.
I'm here for the show.
Let's make it snappy.
Fat chance. We!
Let's scram and catch that picture show
we're shoving off.
La di da.
Who's the host with the most?
You are, you handsome devil?
Bite your tongue
or be sword and bite it for you.
You can bite it or I can bite it,
but either way, it's gone get bit.
Let me introduce you to some friends.
Here a couple of hot tomatoes.
Mum's the word. It's a secret.
Here goes nothing. Hey,
what's eating him?
Spill the beans. We're
just a couple of dumb dumbs.
Zip it ding dong, she don't gotta know
we're a couple of dumb dumbs.
Oh, nuts. That was swell. Neat!
Ah, Banana Royale.
What in tarnation? Dynamite!
Made it!
Jesus boys, it's the cops.
So long fellas.
Toodle-oo.
There we go August 19th I think that's
an announcement of the Cuphead show.
And I love
that Miss Chalice was in that clip
because she's the new playable character
in the DLC
that's coming out in a couple of weeks.
And we were left off with season one
being like, What else happens with her?
Well, what's going to happen?
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, we saw some returning characters
in there as well.
Yeah, the voices are so good.
You play the game
and you don't really think about
what they sound like in real life.
And then when I when we last year
we first met the characters,
and we heard their voice
and it's just so perfect.
It's exactly how we want them to sound.
They have so much fun with each other.
And yeah, the fact that
we got the first season earlier this year
and now the next batch of episodes
coming in August.
Yeah, I'm so excited.
It's so authentic, as you
said, like, this is exactly what I want
Netflix to be doing more of is adding
lore to these gaming worlds and Cuphead
itself is such an amazing series.
So yeah, very exciting.
And if you're anything like us and you're
craving some more throwback animation,
old timey music,
truly just demented adventures.
The Cuphead show is streaming right now
on Netflix
with more episodes on the way this summer.
That's right. August.
All right.
That's that's one of the biggest
announcements of this show for me.
And stick around because later
today, the cast and show runners
are doing a table read
for a brand new episode
of The Cuphead Show
right here on Geeked Week.
So fun all I want to hear
is more of, "Roll the dice!"
Netflix has
been partnering with some of the best
indie devs out there.
And we're going to give you an exclusive
look at three new titles.
All right.
First up, I mentioned earlier indie games.
This is one
that I'm very, very excited about.
It's called Lucky Luna.
And it comes from Snow Man,
who you may know as the company behind
games like Altos, Odyssey and Skate City.
Let's see what they've got.
This is a beautiful, original,
brand new game for Netflix.
Check it out.
Oh, so perfect.
And this is what I want more from
Netflix is completely original games.
Looks like tons of fun.
Has that old school feel to it.
Yeah, that eight bit vibe.
I'm very,
very excited.
This is going to be coming to Netflix
and we got to announce it.
Yeah. And a little bit more about it.
It is a journey written in the stars.
Hidden dungeons, mythical Temple's
mysteries of the past.
That all kind of qualifies
any game to be on my list.
Of something I want to play.
This story is inspired by a Japanese
folktale called
The Tale of the Bamboo Cutter
over a thousand years later.
It's a game which is so awesome.
My dad used to
talk to me about this story.
Yeah, I'm
assuming it's the princess
who is part of the moon.
Like she's one of the moon people
who have been who came to earth
and she was found in a bamboo
by the bamboo cutter.
This is all-I'm piecing it together now.
It's a beautiful story.
You're like an expert on the bamboo
cutter story.
Well, I don't know.
If I'm an expert.
Only-my dad said the story.
And if I was listening correctly as a kid.
He wouldn't lead you astray.
I love that-It's not like there's already
an anime of this on Netflix,
and now they're making a game like this
is, you know, it's
a completely original experience.
And it's a vertical platformer
without a jump button.
Keep that in mind.
So you're swiping to move Luna
as she plunges deeper and deeper
through ancient temples and lost ruins,
which is a genius way
to adapt the usual console kind of side
scrolling gameplay.It's got a story mode,
special challenge rooms,
and an expansive world, but
you have to stay focused to avoid traps,
dodge enemies and collect pearls.
That's what all those little white things
are.
Gotcha.
And endless mode has players competing
on leaderboards to collect the most pearls
or see who makes it the furthest
in each of the game's various levels.
Lucky Luna.
Very excited to announce this one.
It's coming this summer
only on Netflix exclusive independent game
from an acclaimed developer.
As I said,
I want to see more of this from Netflix.
I'm very excited
that we got to announce this
and that people get to play the summer.
Have you
ever wish you could explore your dreams
and memories?
No, never. Dark.
What about your nightmares?
Yes. No, just kidding.
DESTA The memories between is a turn based
strategy game
that's a mix of into the breach,
Hade's inception and dodgeball.
Those are four things I would not think
necessarily fit together.
Yeah. No, especially the last one.
Yeah.
Hades, Dodgeball, Inception. Yeah.
What are we talking about?
Well, in this, you overcome broken
relationships and a tragic family event
all through the medium of a surreal
and exciting ball game.
Let's take a look.
Since I've been home,
I've had such vivid dreams
memories of people in places
of struggle to return to
I'm searchin every night
trying to understand
those words left unsaid.
Stand in my way.
I think I've found a way through
let's see how far it takes us well.
This comes from a really acclaimed
developer in London,
Ustwo Dan Graves is one of the guys there,
I know him well, visited that studio.
And these guys have done a lot
of really acclaimed, independent games.
And here's again a brand new game,
which, as we heard in
the description, is just like
unlike anything else out there.
Desta The memories between.
I am a sucker
for isometric viewpoints in games
and just like you said, really unexpected
things that's mashed together.
And you said isometric--These guys
did Monument Valley, which was such a...
That makes sense.
Classic Indie game had that cool--everyone
remembers
that game a couple of years ago
in the sequels,
and now they've gone on to do a bunch of
other really interesting, unique games.
And this is another one
which is, you know, fully original story
made by an acclaimed mini developer
and coming to Netflix.
Desta The memories between has a rogue
like structure, so the enemies
and the abilities change from run to run.
So it's kind of infinitely replayable
that way.
Be sure to check out this game
when it launches later this year.
All right.
I feel like indie game crew does not
get any better than this one, Geoff.
Oh wow. You're setting up something
pretty big here. Oh, yeah.
All right, well, let's take a look
at some games that are coming to Netflix
from the one and only Devolver Digital.
Devolver has an incredible eye for stylish
exciting games across all genres.
They absolutely do.
They always have fun, crazy,
unexpected games, as you said.
And now we have not one, not two,
but three games
coming to Netflix from Devolver.
First up, it is Reins, Three Kingdoms.
The original Reins took off is a game
that could be described
as Tinder for Monarchs.
I love that.
I'll go with that.
You run your own kingdom
making tough decisions that have rewards
and consequences
meeting others, characters who can change
your destiny with nearly a swipe.
I mean, isn't
that what you're doing with Tinder?
Also coming from Devolver
we have Terra Nil,
the Strategy City Building Game
with an emphasis on the climate crisis.
This is nice to see, right?
Yeah.
In Terra Nil
it's your job to turn a barren wasteland
into an ecological paradise
with flora, fauna, wind turbines,
and wait for it -- water pumps.
Water pumps, water pumps.
We love our water pumps.
Each piece of land
you turn into a lush paradise.
We'll give you points.
That's. That's just lovely, isn't it?
Yeah, it. Is. I mean, warms my heart.
And once you've successfully
saved the environment.
You turn the remaining buildings
into an airship
to leave the beautiful wilds to nature.
Oh, my gosh.
That's altruistic.
I feel a little kind of spoiling the game.
Where are we? Well, I don't know.
I mean, it's a lofty goal to --
To get to your ship.
Yeah.
And then to to beautify it,
and then to be like, you know what?
You're better off
without that airship. Without that.
You think that's like a big blimp,
so you get to take off
and or do you think it's- Like,
I'm thinking.
Like a ship, like Space X rocket?
Probably more that.
And it's probably not steampunk.
We've got wind turbines
and things like that.
You see, these are all the things we're
going to have to find out in Terra Nil.
And then finally, from the creator of
the award winning Downwell, it's Poinpy!
Poinpy.
This is my--I
think this might be my favorite name
for a video game of the year so far.
Poinpy! Poinpy!
I mean, we love to say it.
Poinpy! Everyone in chat right
now. Poinpy!
Poinpy! Hashtag Poinpy.
That's right. Exactly.
I mean, get ready to dodge
adorable baddies and feed the blue beast.
Yes, the blue beast
that's hot on your heels.
That's all coming in Poinpy!
We have the first official look
at Poinpy
big exclusive for you let's check it out.
I didn't
know that
the beast was going to be so cute.
This is a beast- What is Poinpy?
Is Poinpy the character do we think?
I think Poinpy might be the character,
the blue beast is -- Is that like a class?
Like is Poinpy a specific character,
or do you think Poinpy is like a species?
Oh, a species. Look at that.
Look at that art.
I'm like, it's unclear to me who are they?
All are they Poinpies.
That's like the plural of a Poinp.
I feel like Poinpy must be the character.
I mean, it's got a hat and stuff,
you know, it's a it's a it's
an established --
That. Person? Person, no.
Like that's Poinpy,
there's only one Poinpy.
There's only one Poinpy. The or is it?
I don't know many Poinpy.
See. Feed the beast though.
And then it being a cat,
I feel like most pet owners would be like,
yeah, I need to feed the beast.
There's a lot of Poinpy.
We need the Poinpy
Can someone start that up right now?
Start to figure this out.
I can tell you this game
I'm sure is going to be very addictive.
The more you play, you keep going
higher and higher up in the world
and the game, of course,
gets harder and harder. ep.
Bouncing all over the place,
grabbing fruit for the beast across
randomly generated areas filled
with creatures and special abilities.
Plus puzzle mode and endless mode
and even more.
It looks absolutely great, though,
and tons of fun.
And here is the big announcement.
Drumroll, please.
Poinpy is available right now.
That's right. Surprise shadow drop.
Netflix members around the world
can play it today.
Just open up your Netflix
app on your phone and search for Poinpy
to download it and play it right now.
A summer game fest sensation, Poinpy.
Poinpy! Download and play now.
That's so fun.
And that's what I love about Netflix
is this stuff is launching all the time
and their new games
constantly showing up in the app.
Surprises. Yep. That's right.
To say
that Dota has taken the gaming world
by storm over the past two decades,
that's a massive understatement.
Jeff,
you've been to the international, right?
I have a couple of times.
I went to the first international
that was actually in Germany
back in the day,
and I'd been a couple of times
up to the international when they did
the Key Arena,
which is now climate pledge up in Seattle.
And it's it's such a sensation.
I love I mean, all the amazing teams
that have come and part of it.
And even last year
we had a couple of Dota teams
that were nominated at the game awards
from Ukraine, of all places.
It's a truly global game.
And such a phenomenon -- an amazing job.
It's so exciting
being in an e-sports arena.
My goodness.
Yeah.
Dota people love the law
and the characters
and the game has an absolutely massive fan
base and the lore has been
brought to life
in the original series Dota
Dragons, Blood.
Free Yourself.
Your time has come.
This was when this first season came out
a little while ago
and Dota fans were eating good.
And I understand we have something special
for the Dota fans
right now.
And I believe I've been targeted.
All right. I'm sure it's nothing personal.
The arrow is headed right in my direction.
If I don't release all the details
right now on Dota Dragon's Blood,
which is set in a fantasy world of magic
and mysticism, the story follows a dragon
knight Davion, who hunts and slays dragons
to make the world a safer place.
Is it a safer place
if there are fewer dragons in the world?
I'm not sure that's
necessarily true. Right?
And not if you ask the dragons. Exactly.
I say more.
We need more dragons in this world.
Anyways...
Based on the Valve video game Dota
two season
three of Dragons
Blood is coming to Netflix on August 11th
That's exciting.
So August 11th for Dota,
we've got lots of cool stuff
happening in August with the Cuphead Show.
But right now we've got Poinpy.
Have you guys finished
your Poinpy download?
I was going to say
it is available right now.
Now for something completely different.
How about something
as thematically far from Dota as possible?
Something. Something completely.
I don't know, adorable.
Are we announcing Poinpy 2 right now?
Poinpy 2 happening right now?
Downloadable.
Yes. Here is a palate cleanser guys.
Roll it.
You know, I have to admit something.
When I saw this in the script after we'd
done Too Hot to Handle, I was like
Wild Things...is this is a Charlie Sheen
movie made into a game?
Like it's a complete different game.
How risque are we getting?
And we gave you like, no, we're going to
Wild Things. Animal Adventures. All right.
I'm a sucker for these types of games
where it looks like it's a match three
and then you beautify your area.
I love this kind of thing.
Well, how. Look how cute that elephant is.
Now, what's cuter
-- Poinpy or the elephant?
All in the chat, guys. Come on.
No, the wild things are in trouble.
And they need your help, guys.
In Wild Things, you help these cute
beasts restore their wild lands
by playing games and re beautifying
and restoring their environment to health.
And who wouldn't want to help out
these adorable little creatures?
Help them save all kinds of places,
lush forests,
tropical islands, and icy terrains.
And they need your help
very soon.
Very soon.
Yeah, because you can download
wild things on Netflix later this month.
I feel like we need a calendar.
Should we get a Calendar?
I was going to say Poinpy today later
this month.
Wild Thing, August, DOTA, August Cuphead.
But who knows what's beyond that?
All right.
Well, next up, animated series based on
an absolute gaming icon.
That's right.
We're talking about Sonic Prime
and we've got some very exciting news
from some of Sonic's
friends. Let's check it out.
Oh, sorry, big!
Sorry froggy.
Can't chat.
Got to go help our friends.
No problem, Sonic.
I know what you're thinking.
I'm good and powerful apparently!
Jealous.
Sonic has had a big year.
He's got a schedule.
He's got no time for anyone.
I mean.
I mean, how could you have time
when you've got the movie?
The new game Frontiers is coming out later
this year.
He's got his agent on the phone.
Sonic Prime, Sonic, is so long,
it's a pretty big deal these days.
Absolutely.
Sonic Prime is the hedgehog that you know
and love
until an incredible twist
thrust Sonic into a new adventure.
The new series features a reinvented cast
and Sonic like you've never seen him
before, where the fate of the multiverse
rests in his gloved hands.
This time, Sonic's adventure isn't
just a race to save the universe from Dr.
Eggman.
It's a race to save dun,
dun, dun: his friends!
His friend.
Also, I think, saw this
kind of taking his friends for granted.
I have to be honest with you.
Ooh, that's a hot topic.
I mean, how could you take big the cat
or frog for granted?
I mean, oh.
I wish I were getting in there. Wow.
Deep in the sonic lore.
All right, we're going to find out
what happens to Sonic
Froggy and all his other friends.
When Sonic Prime debuts only on Netflix.
OK, so back to the games.
We debuted some today
based on Netflix shows,
saw some fresh ideas
from brilliant indie studios.
What's next, Jeff?
I think we're going to take a look
at a few games you may recognize
they're making their mobile debut
only on Netflix.
First up here is Raji in Ancient Epic.
In this game, you play young Raji
chosen by the gods
to stand against a demonic invasion.
Her destiny to rescue her younger brother
and face the demon lord.
Everyone say it together with me,
Mahabalasura.
Oh, yeah.
See, that's the toughest word
in the show.
It's going to be a blast to play coming
from Nodding Head games later this year.
Mark that calendar.
Now, let's take a look at another
celebrated indie coming soon to Netflix.
This is Spirit Farer.
That was so much to unpack.
It started with like, OK, cool.
It's crafting there's mining
there is building involved.
Oh ok.
It's like got some 2D scroller
type of elements to it.
And then it's like,
learn to say goodbye.
Yes.
Death is a theme in this game, which
came out a couple of years ago on an Xbox.
This developer,
Thunder Lotus Games is up in Canada
and it's a really beautiful game,
as you said, like there's a lot to unpack.
There are deeper than you think.
Spirit
there is the cozy as sweet as game about
yes dying now available
for the first time on mobile.
I never thought I'd ever say that.
That's a really good way to describe it.
My gosh you play is Stella Ferry
Master to the deceased a spirit Farer
build a boat to explore the world,
then befriend and care for spirits
before
finally releasing them into the afterlife.
Yeah, there's so much going on.
As you said in this game, you can spend
relaxing quality time with your spirit.
Passengers create lasting memories
and ultimately learn, as the trailer said,
how to say goodbye.
That's so deep.
My gosh.
It's a beautiful game, very thought provoking and has never been on mobile before.
But now it's going to be.
There you go.
It's such a unique
and creative concept for a game.
So no wonder it's been so popular.
I'm going to stop sleeping on it.
I'm going to play it.
OK, well, if you're looking forward
to Spirit Fair like Mari,
let us know over on Twitter at Netflix
Geeked.
It is so exciting
to see all of these legit mobile games.
I mean, how crazy to go from mailing DVDs
to getting video games
on your mobile device.
I mean, what a glow up Netflix has had.
I know it makes you think like,
what's next?
Mm. Yeah, what is next?
Well, now
we're going to head on over to Wallachia
for a very special gift week announcement.
Don't listen to her richter.
Her and have no choice.
There's always a choice. Sorry.
He knows you kill vampires.
But I prefer to say sorry.
So part of you has died.
We are looking for someone. Richter!
Castlevania's back!
Did I hear Richter?
Yeah, I think you did.
I mean, I feel like Castlevania
really was the O.G.
Netflix gaming show.
If you guys remember. It
set the bar. Bar exactly.
So high.
An incredible franchise
we all know and love from our childhood.
Done so well on Netflix.
And now Castlevania
Nocturne is the new Castlevania
series from showrunner Kevin Colde.
It'll focus on Richter Belmont,
a descendant of Trevor in sci
fi in Maria Reynaud
during the French Revolution.
Castlevania
Nocturne is currently in production,
but be sure to get all the latest updates
on that new series right over on Twitter
at NetflixGeeked.
My gosh, we're good to go.
All right.
We have covered so much today, Mari.
Does that mean
we're like at the end of the show?
I don't know. Don't say it's so Pointy!
I was going
to say there may be a Poinpy surprise.
Yeah. There's a ton more coming, though,
actually.
That's right.
Hard to believe,
but by the end of this year,
there will be over
50 different Netflix games.
So many games.
I mean, games on top of games
on top of games.
It is so exciting.
And here is a taste of everything else
coming our way.
It's amazing.
In a year how far even half year really
how far Netflix has come.
And I was excited to see a lot of those
in the announcements today.
Clearly, games are going to be
a big part of Netflix moving forward
and also gaming series.
So we had a jam packed day.
I can't imagine what Geeked Week
23 is going to look like.
It was a lot today.
So much to look forward to
as well. It was.
And while you're waiting
for all of the new ones to drop,
there are tons of free games
for you to download
right now, such as
-- Poinpy!
Poinpy! Guys were driving it. We're
driving record number of Poinpy downloads.
All right.
Don't go anywhere
because even though the debuts are done,
we're finishing
Geeked Week with a bang, of course.
Up next, the cast and creators
of The Cuphead Show are doing a table
read of a brand new episode
which hasn't even hit Netflix yet.
Another Geeked Week exclusive.
We're going to be watching that for sure.
And then we have the star
of Resident Evil
Live at the Twitch gaming gathering,
so don't miss that.
That's
really fun down at Summer Game Fest.
And to top it all off,
back here at noon Pacific,
join us for a live
episode of the Geeked podcast.
That's right, hosts
Princess Weeks and Tessa Netting.
Hi, Tessa.
We'll chop up the biggest news of the week
and everything you might have missed.
I sure hope Poinpy
is the big headline, but.
It better be.
Otherwise, we'll have something to say.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
All right. So don't go anywhere.
But we're going somewhere to download
Poinpy.
That's right.
All right.
We'll see you guys next year Geeked Week!!
See ya!